[Music]
the prospect of mortality haunts the
human-animal like nothing else
1974 Pulitzer prize-winning book the
denial of death chronicled the ways in
which human beings repress their anxiety
about dying by creating complex symbolic
systems that infuse our lives with some
kind of eternal meaning you will live
forever in the kingdom of God if you are
a moral person or if you find the girl
of your dreams you will rub up against
the sacred and you will be absolved of
all earthly mortality and decay there
are all these sophisticated ways in
which our cognitive apparatus has
conceived of the means through which we
will attain immortality but at the end
of the day everyone dies now for the
first time in history though the
prospect of technologically enabled
eternity is finally here as Magana de
Unamuno wrote in tragic sense of life it
turned any eternity that is the supreme
desire nothing is real that is not
eternal but now my friends were in the
age of biology now my friends were in
the age of genetics now my friends were
the age of CRISPR gene editing never
forget that our genes our little
software programs never forget that we
are made of code never forget that we
are alphabetic all the way down
as we increasingly learn to master the
language of biology to decipher the
language of life to make biology a
programmable medium we will remember we
will be able to engender a kind of God
we will be able to revert to transform
our genetic programming to program our
body away from disease away from aging
we're living in the age a big data for
biology and from this data we will find
patterns we will gain insights we will
gain mastery over the matrix of biology
and what this means my friends is that
we will finally take over the
evolutionary process we will be able to
engender divinity for ourselves we must
never forget we are cosmic
revolutionaries not Stooges unscripted
to advance natural order that kills
everyone right as Dylan Thomas says do
not go quietly into that good night rage
rage rage against the dying of the light
and we've done it gloriously in the past
we've raged against the darkness with
our poetry with our reverie
with our artistry and we will finally do
it with our technology my friends you
know what immortality will be like it'll
be like the line from Robert editor's
merchants of immortality when he says
together we shall drink the wine of
centuries on
we will see tomorrow's beyond measure we
will have a front seat in the greatest
show of all time we will witness
transformation we will witness evolution
we will never disappear this is our
destiny this is our birthright this is
the purpose of sentience to trump
entropy to move beyond decay greater
complexity greater organization the
greatest melodies yet to be written the
greatest songs yet to be sung we will
sing the songs that orchestrate the
universe we will be gods beyond measure
this is not a dress rehearsal this is
our chance to internalize ourselves
let's do it
I'm in sign me up